recevra 1 et présidente de la
coopérative agricole des huiles
essentielles de borbon et aussi des
plantes médicinales au salon situé sur
le monde je suis vieux jeu le monde
extérieur j'avais trois gros rendez vous
avec trois grosses sociétés c'est la
première fois ça arrive donc bah j'irai
les bras que je vais voir le jeu voit ce
qu'ils veulent de la réunion ils savent
que je
que mon code métier c'est le géranium
donc je pense qu'ils vont
interrogé ce match sera mien alors
pendant le salon chez toutes les huiles
de la réunion les huiles essentielles de
la réunion j'ai aussi les huiles du
monde je dirais des huiles alimentaires
des huiles de massage des huiles
des huiles vierges et de parfums ça
aussi j'ai des autres parfois avec bien
sûr on privilégie les produits de la
réunion à l'oeuf à ramona la rose
bourbon on a une au géranium on a du
vétiver
j'ai des tisanes j'ai une crème de jour
et une crème de nuit à base que de
produits naturels des ambianceurs pour
parfumer la maison
et puis mes tisanes vous savez comme moi
j'étais jeune j'ai mon géraniums c'est
notre culture patrimoniale qu'on est
mondialement connue quand même grâce à
notre géraniums 2010 lève on avait fait
un très bon salon j'espère que
en 2022 je dirais à notre président je
dirais à au président mais le client
merci j'ai fait mieux que 2019 je tenais
quand même à remercier monsieur melchior
et monsieur serge waro parce que depuis
qu'ils s'occupent du salon on a vraiment
guéri un village regnery ce qu'on
n'avait pas avant voir